i give up my dream and get a nine to
five
is
we will be paying for that and you guys
need to sit down with a really good
oh see i don't know i should check on
these things before i go on the air and
do this and put the 17 million people
so yeah i was talking about one of my
buddies says when he goes to his
mother-in-law's house
it was crazy he said he just does bobble
head the whole oh
i like that there's no sense engaging
because it's not going to change
anything
right so he long ago gave up trying to
fix her
crazy butt and he just says i got three
days of bobblehead and then i get to
come back home
that's a wise wise friend of mine that's
kind of like i thought that was pretty
good
i i can't do it you have to paint on the
smile see i don't
you can't use the bobble heads does not
have a working mouth
see i love it a bobble head gets you
through a lot of things in life
sometimes
but you can't though you can't you can
just spiritually and psychologically
bless your heart
yeah you know i can at least say that
bless your heart which can mean a lot of
things that's right
if you're from the south we should do a
book on just the various possible
meanings and intonations and pauses
in the phrase bless your heart
that you you can say it yeah one way one
way means bless your heart one minute
means you're my idiot
one way means i'm getting ready to punch
your lights out i mean you can say a lot
of different things with that one phrase
so and it's been going on a lot this
year so anyway if you got uh
mental health questions the doctor's in
the house and we're not
talking about me open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five you jump in we're
gonna start with matt he's in colorado
springs
hey matt how are you hey good day merry
christmas
merry christmas to you sir hey i'm a
retired military member coming up on
just about 26 years of service getting
ready to retire
and one of the benefits that we earn is
the ability it's called the survivor's
benefit plan
it allows for the withhold 6.5
of my retirement pay in order to secure
half of that pay for my spouse up until
her death
should i pass away before her um you pay
into it for
30 years and then you stop having to pay
into it but you are kind of locked into
it so
it's not really a small it's not a term
yeah it's
just a survivor benefit on your
retirement for your military it's a very
simple question
and i think i haven't seen you talk
about it i've listened for a while i
haven't heard you just wonder what your
thoughts were on it
thank you for your service how old are
you i'm about 43.
how's your health uh it's pretty good i
do have solid term life insurance that
will take me through the next uh
25 years so i feel pretty comfortable in
that part it's sort of the
after that point that i'm kind of having
a hard time making that decision
okay here's the formula if you take the
difference
in the two plans let's say you took the
without survivor which is the big payout
right and the difference and you took
the difference in those two plans and
you invest it
and at seven percent it will break even
at 10 or 12 you will
based on your normal death age which is
74. okay
and um i suspect that's what they're
running it on but they run their numbers
out at seven percent
and so the answer to the equation is
this the longer you
live the dumber the idea
is that you took the survivor benefit
right because you get less money for a
longer period of time
and didn't need the benefit see
or worse yet you outlive her
and you paid all this money in for it
and so if you're young and healthy like
you are
and you've got term insurance to cover
her should something happen to you and
this benefit die with you
i would take the gamble and i would
continue to invest
and again were you to invest that
difference you can sit down with a smart
investor pro and they can tell you
at what point you'd have enough lump sum
to pay out what you would have paid out
okay so what is the six and a half
percent what's the difference right now
in dollars
uh in dollars uh so the retirement's
gonna be about sixty thousand dollars
so i don't have a calculator with me but
it's six and a half percent
is six and a half percent of about 350 a
month yeah
about what 300 yeah so about 3 600 300
let's call it 4 000
yeah a year or a month yes yes
a year a year okay what does it take to
create four thousand dollars a year
in investments well at ten percent
that'd be forty thousand dollars
so at the point you take four hundred
dollars a month and invest it
and it grows to forty thousand dollars
now the forty thousand dollars will pay
off
the four hundred dollars if you die or
if you don't die
you see that's your break-even point if
you die before this gets to four
before the four hundred dollars grows to
40 000
then you lost money on my idea
right but if you live long and you will
you're going to live well past this when
you run the numbers out it's going to be
a no-brainer
because it's going to be i don't i can't
do it in my head i don't have my
calculator laying here but
but bottom line is you're gonna probably
about the 20-year mark about the time
you're in your 60s
is when uh you're going to have the 400
would have technically grown to enough
to create 400.00
a month a year difference and or a month
difference
four thousand dollars a year so um
uh so that's what you're looking at and
um
if in the meantime you keep term
insurance so she's taken care of if you
die and you don't she doesn't have this
pension
then you're going to come out better off
so from a math standpoint now if you
told me you were
ill or you had had a
a debilitating disability that could
indicate
earlier death or something like that
then we might rethink this
but the longer you're going to live the
dumber it is to have taken
mathematically
the dumber it is to have taken the
survivor benefit and keep so i'd buy a
20-year level term
and i think by then you'll break even
sit down with smart visitor pro and run
it out both of you fund your roth iras
both of you continue to build other
wealth and she's going to be just fine
without this when you die
and she probably will outlive you 75
percent of the ladies do outlive their
husbands
very interesting when you look at their
lifestyle usually it makes that makes
sense
so people make a lot of dumb math
decisions
based on a lack of appetite for risk
yeah
yes and then somebody's always there
with a package to
buy the risk from you right exactly that
doesn't make sense long term
exactly and that's the survivor benefit
is truly about or make sure my wife's
taken care of yep which is a great
noble sure thing is there a better way
to do it
and statistically what comes out the
better way to do it is buy some term
life insurance to take care of something
happens to you
and throw extra money into investments
right so that it offsets
the fact that she's not going to get
that and i have been so guilty of that
and just sitting here at this desk it's
like an extended warranty it's the same
thing that's exactly right but just
sitting at the desk
it doesn't work never done the math math
doesn't work that that thing on your car
never breaks it's always the other thing
that's the other thing right you know
that's the way the extended warranty
works they
they weren't dumb when they drew those
things up they're not a present for me
right
merry christmas merry christmas dr john
delony ramsey personality my co-host
today we're answering your questions
about life and money this is the dave
ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
one of the things that makes the dave
ramsey show unique from other shows
is that we genuinely care about our
listeners
that's why we are very intentional about
choosing
our advertisers blinds.com
offers high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and then their customer service is truly
unbeatable
they make it simple to shop for blinds
shades and interior shutters from home
with easy online ordering and
free shipping right to your door and
blinds.com
will help you every step of the way just
like they've helped
thousands of my listeners with free
design help
by phone and online plus they guarantee
the perfect fit go today
and take advantage of this week's
special offer
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today
this is the dave ramsey show open phones
eight eight two five
five two two five as we talk about your
life
and your money our question today comes
from blinds.com find out for yourself
why blinds.com
is the number one online retailer of
custom window coverings
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run all the
time you'll save even more
always use the magic word the promo code
is
ramsey save you some money all right
today's question comes from tyler in
north dakota
tyler says i've been dating this girl
for three years
and she was never taught about money
growing up so i've tried to teach her
over the last few years
she just had her come to jesus moment
and wants to change but she recently
lost her job
and now she can't afford rent for this
next month i make decent money and i'm
pretty far ahead
should i lend her 350 dollars so she can
try and come out on her feet or should i
let should i watch and let her learn
from her mistakes
no you don't lend money okay if you
uh good answer been dating for three
years so this is a tricky one
dave because they've been together for
three years if he wants to give her some
money
um three years is a long time that's an
invested relationship i don't personally
like that either
when you start bailing out your
boyfriend or girlfriend that can get
messy
short-term man long-term but three years
if he said we were engaged we were gonna
get married that's one thing but
man this feels this feels like a
slippery slope and a messy mess if you
ask me
what do you think dave uh well i i agree
with you
uh so explain what you mean
like this is gonna change the it's gonna
change the tone of their relationship
yeah i mean just reading through this
question um
his job isn't to try and teach the
person that he loves unless she's asking
for it and she's interested in some of
these moments and i've been guilty of
trying to quote unquote
try and teach my wife some things over
the years that after 15 20 years
together i realized
oh she was way ahead of me on those
things right she was bobble heading here
right
and obviously you never lend somebody
that you care about no no no no no no
no no no no you just don't lend people
money period when you're dating somebody
and you give them money you give he
gives her 350 bucks he gives her 500
bucks
the power dynamic of this relationship
shifts and suddenly she's beholden to
him
even though he's gonna give it to her
and let's just say
that he is a perfectly noble
guy and has zero
negative power feelings toxic power
feelings about giving her the money he
just gave it to her and he's just he's a
great guy and he's no big deal
the water off a duck's back but the way
she feels she's gonna take that
she could change with shane that's
exactly she feels beholden and i'll tell
you right now he's not dave he's
somebody that's gonna
use this opportunity to teach her and to
give her some lessons
and to give her some information and man
he's just you're setting up your
relationship
for a mess yeah and so the only way it's
you're gonna pull it off is
you're gonna have to say all these
things out loud that's exactly right and
you're gonna have to go
the problem with me doing this is it
could end up with this and this and this
and this and this
and we can't have that so i'm giving you
this money there is no strings i'm not
going to teach you or talk to you or
whatever and you can't
you can't act like weird after this
that's right
you can't change you know you've got to
just be normal you got to just pretend
like the transaction didn't
happen and uh you don't owe me anything
nope you don't owe me a bad head you
don't
owe me honor you don't owe me
uh the money back uh you don't owe me
sexual favors you don't owe me
anything right and you just gotta really
say
all of this out loud because when you
say it out loud it go
it leaves the room it loses its power on
yeah right then when you're shining the
light on the room the roaches run out
that's exactly right
and i might sit her down and say would
you be interested in
in this because if i sometimes my gift
to you can be a burden for somebody else
right
if you're having this kind of
conversation you need to put i love that
put it all on the table
and then ask would you be willing to
accept this game and before you put it
on the table just go this is awkward as
crap it's super weird if you say
something's awkward before it's awkward
it's less awkward
every time that's exactly right yes so
yeah
this is going to be weird yeah we would
do that with difficult conversations
inside this building all the time we go
look it's going to be a difficult
conversation as soon as you say that
it changes the room and dave and it's
less difficult
i've had several people have to tell me
that since i've worked here
doloney this is going to be weird it's
going to be one of those weird
conversations
that involves you that's not true but
it's a good joke and it's super true i
love it open phones at triple eight
eight two five
five two two five we're talking about
you your life
and your money john is in jacksonville
florida hey john welcome to the dave
ramsey show
hey how you doing merry christmas merry
christmas how can we help
so uh first of all thank you for the
program my wife and i are on baby steps
four five and six
great we're able to pay off quite a bit
of debt in the last couple years
great um we now have a three-year-old
and another child on the way in february
that we are super excited about
and we have started looking into um
schools
and started thinking about school we
love the area we're in
and the house we own but it's not in a
great school district
so in trying to be intentional with our
money we
um are looking at the future and either
to move
um into a better school district would
cost us probably
um about 150 000 more than our current
house
is worth um and the private school in
our district
is roughly 14 000 a year
and we were trying to figure out if it
would be more beneficial
to um move and then at least we have
equity in the house or if we like the
house stay and do private school
i do i did listen to the podcast from
anthony o'neil i know
there was no major difference between
private universities and public
universities
um but i'm not sure that applies to
grade schools and i just want to get
your opinion
what's wrong with your school john what
did you what do you not like about it
so the school it doesn't perform
particularly well
um unfortunately the area that we're in
a lot of people send their kids to
private school so the school actually
draws kids from all different areas um
and it doesn't
um but sometimes those sometimes
academics
sometimes those global scores can
represent a number of different
um metrics throughout a school you're
i'm more interested in your kids
experience with their teachers with the
administrators
administration how's your channel not
there yet there are three oh they're
three okay yeah you're right
i missed that so here's what i would do
before
and and dave's got 30 years of wisdom on
this but
um i've lived in and out of the schools
my wife
has studied schools in banana schools i
would sit down
with the principal i would sit down with
the school counselor
and have some detailed conversations
with them about your concerns
asks for some details about their their
metrics
and those metrics just don't tell you a
whole lot sometimes
and they don't tell you how great the
teachers are how good the administrators
are some of the things they're doing
that are going to be different two and
three and four years from now we just
went through this in my house and i'm so
glad we did because the public school
that my son
ended up at is has been magic it's been
wonderful for him for our family for
everybody
but my wife went and had some hard
conversations with them and they were
excellent
yeah and walked the halls with her
permission uh you'll
get a vibe you'll get a feel on what's
happening in there is it clean
are people happy or is it a prison
and um i mean i've spoken in high
schools i got razor wire around them
you know and so um you know some of
these areas are tough
and uh um right you know if you if you
walk in there you get that prison vibe
thing you move on right so uh the second
thing is this
i generally when two options are
negative
uh expensive private school that i may
or may not be getting value from
150 000 upgrade in-house in order to get
to a better thing
if i only have two options and both of
them suck that means i don't have enough
options
and so i'm challenging the hundred and
fifty thousand dollar move up in order
to get your kid in an acceptable school
that may or may not be true but you may
or may not be moving up in house as well
i mean like you went from that 2 500 to
that 3 500 square foot house oh i caught
you okay
and so that's what it was uh it could be
that it could be area
it could be those things but there may
be another way another neighborhood
another nuance of a neighborhood
if school system is the only thing do
you move down a little bit in home
and up a little bit in location and then
the numbers aren't different
uh so sometimes we get this stuck in our
head and it's like
oh it's going to be 200 000 more to live
over there when you get over and look
around you start thinking yeah we could
buy that one fix it up
buy a foreclosure there's other ways to
skin this cat let's
keep working the problem here so work
both parts of the problem and you'll get
a better answer
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country or have a
better life
the army national guard can help get you
there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today here on the air
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five if you feel like you should
have made more progress paying off your
debt by now
i understand when it comes to paying off
debt sometimes it feels like all grind
and no reward here's the thing
when you try to do it by yourself on
your own you're more likely to fall back
into old habits
you're more likely to cheat around the
edges and that's when you stop making
the progress
and that's why you need to be on the
plan ramsey plus
ramsey plus is our step-by-step money
plan that will give you the
accountability and practical tips you
need
to pay off your debt faster than you can
on your own when you have someone in
your corner cheering you on
you make the tough choices that get you
where you want to be ramsay plus helps
you go from sort of to all in
and you can finally keep more of your
money you can start a free trial right
now
ramsay plus text the word trial 233
789 that's trial two three three
seven eight nine michael's in sacramento
hey michael welcome to the dave ramsey
show
hey thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
hey um so quick little back story i took
fpu about a little over a year ago
i'm on baby step two i was about 23 000
in debt
uh right now i should actually be out of
debt here in about a next month or two
excellent um what my question is
is that i bought a house about three
years ago
uh on a 30-year fix that 4.375 percent
i'm kind of looking at the you know
refinancing right now
it's looking from what i'm seeing uh 30
years about in the high two percent or a
15 year in the mid to low twos
um my take-home pay is about 56 000 a
year
uh my current mortgage is about 1282
with property tax and insurance and
everything
uh what i'm wondering is is this
something i should be looking into
refinancing
or you're gonna stay in your suggestion
yes yeah you need to refinance
so your balance is what
uh the current balance on the house
is 182 000. okay so every one percent
you save is 1800 bucks a year
regardless of what the payment is the
interest being charged to you as a part
of that payment is eighteen hundred
dollars less per year for every one
percent you save
okay now so if it costs you three
thousand six hundred dollars to
refinance
which is probably pretty close if you
save eighteen hundred dollars a year
and it costs you three thousand six
hundred dollars how long does it take
you to break even
answer two years
okay and everything after you pay back
the 3600 with the 1800 savings is gravy
on the biscuit 1800 a year
now you're going to not have that happen
in cash flow
because your payment is going to go up
because you're going to go to a 15 year
but while your payment went up your
interest went down
and so your overall cost on the mortgage
is going to go down substantially for
two reasons
one is you're only going to have it 15
years and two is
you're going to pay 1800 less per year
in actual interest cost so this is a
no-brainer you refinance this
okay even so if i do that 15-year and
the payment's going up
because it seems like that would put me
over you know your suggestion of
you know not spending more than 25 of
your take-home pay
yeah you've already spent that though
yeah we're just structuring and
admitting it now so what will what will
the payment be
did they quote it to you um
no no i haven't gotten an actual quote
on that yet and what do you do for a
living
uh i'm in retail what's that mean
what do you think so well i'm a manager
for a retail store
in the outdoor industry how long have
you been doing that
uh let's see 15 years now okay
so uh five years from now what will your
income be
what's your trajectory on your income is
it not going up
uh yeah it's going up now that you made
store manager you're going to see this
56 turn into
76 fairly soon aren't you
yeah yeah that's what i'm hoping for
yeah and so the 15
or the 15 year being 25 of your
take-home pay is going to solve itself
with your income going up
if you were working for the government
and you're gonna get a three percent of
your raise i'd be more concerned but
your trajectory on your income is going
to solve the math problem for us
not this year but within three years so
you're going to be just fine there and i
love it you just called that dave
you've already you know you've got
someone here trying to do the math and
say this puts somewhere 25
we're already over that we're just being
honest about it now right that
twenty-five percent
don't buy a house on a 15-year fixed
where the payment is more than a fourth
of your take-home payment that's right
but when you already
own the house it's like someone says oh
when i sell my car i'm gonna lose six
thousand dollars on it because i owe six
thousand more than it's worth right now
honey you've already lost it that's
right
when you sell the car you just admitted
it that's right but it's already gone
and that's the case here there you go
you know it's the same thing you're
already there
by just restructuring it now we're
saying ouch this house was a pinch
even with a better interest rate it was
a pinch but it's not going to remain
that way because the trajectory of your
income so i'm doing it anyway i love it
game on instagram from jacqueline
here's a good one riddle me this how do
i make sure that my dad with severe
depression feels loved
even when he treats me badly
purposefully
and purposefully says hurtful things to
me
you gotta draw hard boundaries there
peop people
need to feel loved but they don't have
permission to hurt you
in route to that love right and so
you may write him a letter you may hold
firm boundaries but you number one
don't let anybody hurt you with or
without your permission
so you don't solve his depression by
getting abused absolutely not
becoming a punching bag as a matter of
fact that will probably harm his
depression it will make it worse because
he makes him feel like the schlep that
he is
so what somebody like that needs is
really firm boundaries from someone that
cares about them and they will lean up
against those boundaries and see if
they're real and if they hold and if
they're firm
and then if you write them a letter they
can hold something right it's tangible
they can see it then go back to it then
go back to it and as they get well
as he puts in the work that only he can
put in
then he can he can reinterpret that
letter over time but yeah so what's the
letter sound like
dear dad things are dark and i want you
to know that i love you
i have and things have been hard and you
haven't treated me fairly over the years
you haven't treated or maybe not fairly
you've hurt me over the years and i want
you to know i forgive you and i love you
and it's short and it's sweet and it's
direct you may not even have to
to include the abuse part in there but
just let somebody know that they're
loved that they can circle back to it
and circle back to it
okay so that's the encouragement correct
without the uh
physical presence to allow the abuse
absolutely not okay
and so you're standing there later in
the kitchen
because it's christmas and uh
he says something nasty then we will
already have
me and my family already have had that
discussion and
we will pack up our things and we'll
walk out the door and i will not go on a
vacation where i don't have enough money
to go to a hotel if i don't need if i
with an abusive family member that um
i can't leave right i won't have already
had that conversation with my wife
right um and it'll be no fanfare will be
no drama i'm the one that went into that
knowing this could happen
we're going to pack my things up i'm not
going to hold it too tightly and then
we're going to go
nobody has permission to hurt me or my
family and that starts with my boundary
so it's up front you know we don't we're
not gonna we're not gonna do this
correct
so if you're gonna do this that's gonna
mean we can't be here
correct so i don't have anybody abusive
in my family but
i've got a whole herd of people coming
to my house and i sent an email saying
here's where everyone's sleeping
arrangements are going to be here's what
they're going to look like who's going
to share a bathroom and who's not
here's what we will not talk about while
we're here and here's what we are going
to do while we're here which is going to
be low-key and peaceful and chill
and we're going to be respectful we're
going to spend a lot of time outdoors
and i want to give everybody notice up
front you are free to not come and we're
going to love you
and if that's not where you're at this
year great but i don't want people to
come and be surprised and then there to
be tension
i'm just going to call it call it what
it is before everybody gets there
and that's me trying to be have
boundaries and be mature and know what
i'm getting with my lovely family who's
coming in a number of times grown kids
go back to their old home
and who sleeps where is a problem
there's probably a book in that of
course there is wow
and it's strange too right this is the
dave ramsey
[Music]
[Music]
ah
dr john deloney joins me today is my
co-host ramsey personality best-selling
author of the book redefining anxiety
what it is what it's not and how to get
your life
back tyler is with us tyler is in
california hi tyler welcome to the dave
ramsey show
hey dave dr john doloni so nice to talk
to you guys thank you too
you too what's up uh just want to
first stay uh my wife and i are so
thankful for everything you guys do at
ramsey solutions and just really
appreciative well thank you so my
question today
yeah my question today is i inherited a
trust
that was set up for my grandfather who
passed away when i was a baby
um and my wife and i just aren't quite
sure what we want to do with it so i
thought we'd call you and
if you have any advice i would use it
for where you are on the baby steps
okay where are you so we're on baby's
butt we're on baby step seven
oh well that's that's the then you're
down to investing right
so how much is in the truck how much is
in the trust
there's a little it's right around 219
000.
and what's it put what's it invested in
so it's broken into
33 of its cash 15 in a cd
and 170 is in bonds okay so we know it's
not invested in what
in what you teach and we have our other
retirement stuff invested in
yeah yeah so i would sit down with a
smartvestor pro
and i would make a plan for investing it
um
i only invest in two things growth stock
mutual funds and real estate that i pay
cash for
those are the only two things i invest
in i don't i don't play
any other stuff i'm not a big player i'm
kind of boring
and because i discovered most people
that are wealthy or boring
with their money they're not flash and
dash and
they don't have all these plans and all
this stuff they talk about the golf
course people talk about stuff at the
golf course are like people that say
they caught a big fish
they're full of crap and um they just
they're mouthing off and they they
act like they got something they don't
have the guy that says he hasn't got any
money grab your wallet because he's
probably got some
uh so you know that's that's the kind of
stuff we look at there so just
i'm boring and i give you permission to
be boring
uh and then there's only three things
you can do with money invest it give it
and live it and you ought to do all
three
all the time with all your money you
need to enjoy some of it you need to be
generous with some of it and you need to
be investing it at all times you could
do that off of the proceeds
that this creates in terms of the income
that this uh 200 000
invested creates maybe it creates a
couple thousand dollars a month that you
it's fun money we're gonna uh do
something lifestyle with it we're gonna
be
be
outlandishly generous we're just going
to walk up and pay for people's gasoline
at the gas station just blow about 10
people's minds an hour for
just for the fun of it i mean you just
go do fun stuff
i mean just blow you know have some
crazy outrageously generous moments
and um by the way you should budget for
that
it's not necessarily random or impulsive
when it happens might be but you ought
to just be walking around with
a couple grin in your pocket at all
times going hmm what you up to today god
and you can do that stuff when you're on
baby step seven and you got two hundred
thousand from your grandpa
well done sir very cool yeah it sets you
up at a different thing you can
you just you'll start seeing stuff
when you budget for it and you because
you have to
intentionally look for it and what where
you're looking for positive things
negative things
people that you can help people that are
out to get you when you're looking for
it that's what you're going to find
right that's what you're going to see
yeah it's the um the old thing the
reticular activator thing if
you know i start looking at buying a
green car and also and i see green cars
everywhere that's the same thing and so
um
same thing here when you start looking
for the opportunity to be randomly
generous you start hearing
three aisles over in the grocery store a
kid crying and you look over and momma's
crying and the
card was denied three times and you go
that bag
or that bucket a basket of groceries is
on me
i got that one and you get to have these
moments when you've got the money
walking around and you're baby step
seven you got no payments
house is paid for us what that means
what a way to go man way to go you're
killing it
nicole is with us in new york city hi
nicole how are you
hi dave thank you for taking the call
sure how can i help
so um i recently received inheritance
from my mother
she passed away earlier this year from
kobe and
so my husband and i every once in a
while we sit there and we look at our
bills
um for me i don't have any credit cards
i just have my student loans in the
house
and what i discovered um my husband was
able to give me any money because at one
point he had
gotten into so much debt he got a
consolidation loan and plus he had his
alimony and child support which are now
done so
um you know i do the bills you know i
sit down with the bills
every month and every every once while
he wasn't doing it with me so i finally
set out outright
it's like what is your debt because
there's no money coming in from your
side
and now he's back in debt again so with
the inheritance of i'm trying to decide
whether i should pay off my student loan
um i mean the payments like 800 a month
or
really aggressively attack the mortgage
because i'm a little concerned
about the future we're both 50. yeah how
much student loan debt do you have
um 118 000 and what is your uh
income i make 115.
what's your husband um mike about 150
he both um okay so 230 household income
yes and your uh inheritance is how much
um 75 000. and how much debt does he
have
he has right now um what he told me
recently is about
82 000 in credit cards okay
all right you can't make enough
or strategize enough to come out of this
disaster
with your skin intact unless he stops
being stupid
you cannot there's not a strategy that
will offset
him overspending and mismanaging at the
level that he is
it's kind of like saying he's got cancer
and it doesn't affect me
yeah it does when somebody's got cancer
everybody in the house is affected
yes they don't all have cancer but they
all are impacted by the fact that
there's cancer in the house
and nicole your question about paying
off your house sounds like
it's a question rooted in safety
defensive mechanism because you think
he's gonna
continue to screw up or he's going to
bail on you
um well so earlier in our marriage only
been married
eight years he did have an affair and he
left the house
so we reconciled the 2018 but
i told them there's a reason why you
have a patent every two years
just getting in crazy debt with credit
cards and so
we're not back at that same point are
you guys have you guys seen a marriage
counselor i
was um suggesting one he has it
okay um one right there's two there's
two things
here's the answer to your question then
okay you do not need to pay off your
mortgage
and you do not need to pay off your
student loans you need to park the
inheritance
in a separate account with your name on
it only
and you need to demand marriage
counseling
and the two of you need to get on the
same page and you need to see a bright
hopeful future together
and then when you do that then the two
of you need to combine your incomes
and combine your goals and combine your
problems
your student loan problem his former
credit card debt problem because he no
longer is going to have one after you go
through ramsey plus and
financial peace university together and
both of you are on the same team
if your husband is unwilling to do all
of these things
see there nothing can remain in a status
quo
it can't remain where it is so your
marriage is
either going to get worse or it's going
to get better
i'm telling you to take some steps to
make it better and get the two of you on
the same page with a
joint set of goals financially
emotionally maritally everything else
you do not have those now
you got one foot out the door in divorce
because the way you're preparing all of
your money stuff is as if this is ending
when you got back in touch when you got
back together with him in 2018 it sounds
like you hedged that
relationship yep that you were gonna
split money
you were gonna keep doing your thing but
you would take this guy back
because either you were lonely or you
missed him is that fair
well actually um no actually when he
came back
i was like okay we'll put the accounts
back together again because he separated
them
and then he just chose not to put the
accounts back together again so that
since 2018 there are fractures in your
relationship that are causing you to
play defense
and i'm telling you you can't play
defense enough to solve those
you've got to solve those one way to
other but you're all going to fall in
those cracks
yeah you're going to end this thing
because it won't work
or you're going to bring it together and
heal it and figure out with some help
how to do that
and then you can have some joined goals
in the meantime i'm parking this money
over the side because i don't know what
you're going to be facing
next 12 months is going to be rowdy i
know that this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
the total debt is around six hundred and
forty thousand dollars
i'm wanting to come clean about a credit
card that he doesn't know about i'm
gonna probably pay student loans for the
rest of my life
i just don't even know where to begin
and i don't know what to do but i'm
scared
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the
dave ramsey show cash is taking the
place
i'm dave ramsey your host you jump in
we'll talk about your life and your
money it's a free call
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five dr john deloney ramsey
personality
author of the best-selling book
redefining anxiety
is my co-host today here on the air as
we talk about your life and your money
again triple eight eight two five five
two two five shelby's in tampa
florida hi shelby how are you
hi dave thanks for taking my call i'm
great thank you
good how can i help my question
is this um i want to know what i should
be doing with my income
we've gotten to a point that all of our
debt is paid off and we have a couple
hundred
left after we do our every dollar budget
out of my husband's income
i work sales i actually sell real estate
um
i'm wondering i know you say 15 but i'm
45
and i personally only have about 22 000
saved towards my retirement
so i need to kick it up i don't want to
work till i'm 100
and my husband would love to retire
sooner so how much he's already putting
inside the 15
but how much should i take from my check
to put into retirement
and also pay off our mortgage those are
the two things i want to do with my
money what do you think is a realistic
split
i think it should quit being your money
i know but no i know but no i don't know
but
yeah i think it should quit being your
money
and i think he should have quit having
his money in his retirement we
have a retirement plan we have money
and we are going to combine them and of
our household income
we are going to save 15 until our home
is paid off and when it is paid off
we're going to save even more
and we are going to be retire able to
retire with dignity
his 401k should have your name on it as
the beneficiary
your ira should have his name on it
as the beneficiary mm-hmm
it does i just get nervous because real
estate is not always consistent it has
been for the past couple years but
because it's not consistent
i almost look at it as bonus money so i
like attempted to like put half into
you know half of my checks into my
retirement and half of it towards the
mortgage and just like
knock it out you know that's that's what
i'm tempted to do and i don't know if
that's the right thing
it's not but you're saying you're saying
mortgage first no
i'm saying the right thing is that the
two of you combine all of your finances
so we've got his 200 surplus plus
anything you make it sounds like his
gravy as well
and we're going to apply all of that
we're looking at our total household
income we're putting 15 percent of what
we estimate
our total household income it's an
estimate because we don't know exactly
what you're going to make but we know
what you made last year and we know what
you're trekking for this year
and you can't predict real estate
exactly i know that but you're not going
to be off 100
you're not going to be off 50 you're
going to know fairly close to what
you're going to make what'd you make
last year
about 100 okay what's the chances of you
making 40 this year
none unless you sit on your butt
right right right okay so the chances
are pretty good you're gonna be 100-ish
is that fair uh-huh yeah might make a
little more might make a little less
might make a lot more and that'd be
awesome we'll deal with that problem if
we run into it
so what's he make
um his gross is about 80 but his net is
about
4 200. we're dealing with gross for the
15
so let's say you made 120 he made 80.
let's call that 200. and let's just say
that's our estimate for 2021
and that's an easy 30 000. that's 2500 a
month needs to be going into retirement
that's 15 stick to the 15 total okay
then above that let's get the house paid
off because
yeah with you it has the exact same
effect of what your emotions are telling
you you want to do
we're putting money in investments and
we're paying off the house both of those
things lead to security
true both of those things lead to you
catching up or you feel like you're
behind
and you know what else it does for you
shelby
again i hope i'm not projected into i am
i'm directly projecting you called us
it's gonna keep you from feeling like
the little helper around your house
you're an integral part of that home
you're not just the little helper
and you've got this this idea that
your husband's the breadwinner he's off
trucking and just whatever and this is
this is fun money hobby money yeah
whatever nickel and dimes you come up
with will help you feel a little more
secure and you actually make more than
he does you make way more than he does
you're a chief contributor in this house
and probably a hundred different
ways but when you have his money and
your money
you also have his house and your house
and his roles and your roles and it
keeps you from having a united front in
this home
and it might like you said dave you put
all the money in a pot it may be that
200 of dollars that technically is
what's left over
goes to his home depot fund or goes to
his puzzle building i don't know what
weird things he does
and then your money goes to x y and z
the same dollar amount it's not your
money anymore
but you've got to get off this we're
just i'm just out playing around
frivolously and look we had a good year
or two
y'all are on the same team same house
same psychology
same emotion same spirit and same
financial journey here yeah
yeah and they're just different it's um
and sometimes when you
can't predict your income because it's
straight commission or self-employed
it feels less valid yeah
i mean like my grandmother my grandpa
worked for alcohol aluminum for 38 years
and even when i was making seven figures
doing this little radio thing i do
she would bless her heart in her you
know in her she kept asking me when i
was gonna get a real job that's right
that's right because
because i wasn't on anybody's payroll
you know
and it's just there's something that's
invalid about that income if it's not
if it's not quote steady or predictable
that's right and it is
it's it's actually more valid uh because
more tied to actual
value being added every day but the uh
so
yeah that's part of it here's the thing
um
it's a very practical thing you make
different decisions you make
better decisions and you're more unified
when you stop using the wrong pronouns
and you start saying we
ours us our household income is this
and i contribute this amount he
contributes that amount to our household
income
our goals are this i want to feel good
at retirement
from the combination of our retirement
plans
should something happen to him i want to
feel like um
i'm going to be okay in that and that's
a valid goal a valid
value to have in the process
uh but the other thing that ends up
happening is it enhances your
relationship
dramatically you folks i get these calls
every day just about on this show
and i always talk about you know change
your pronouns to we you're french now
wee-wee
and so but john over the years i i'll
never forget the first time it happened
i can even show you exactly where i'm
standing in a hallway
outside of a meeting room we were
teaching financial peace university with
an overhead projector
and this affluent couple was in
financial peace university which in the
early days
hardly any affluent people came they
were all just completely stone cold
broke
nowadays everybody goes to it because we
can all know we can do better
and they come out after the class was
over and they said you've completely
changed our marriage
and i went dude the sex classes down the
hall i didn't
how did i change your marriage and they
started by making us work together we
combined our goals we combined our fears
we combined our dreams and we've been in
marriage counseling
with five different counselors over 18
years and they weren't able to do this
and we were able to do it because of
stupid budget
i love it because you gave him a tool
you didn't say just talk about it and
feel it and talk about it i feel it you
give them
small contact steps to combine your
vision
and then you gotta go do it that's what
a budget does it's an action step
this is the dave ramsey show
if you're financially conscious you know
that healthcare expenses can take a big
bite out of your budget
christian healthcare ministries or chm
is here to help trim those expenses
and make sure your family is cared for
chm
is not health insurance but it is
christians helping
other christians by sharing each other's
medical bills
most people have the means to pay for
basic doctor services but
when it comes to something on a much
larger scale save
several thousand dollars for surgery or
hospitalization
folks are worried they'll be left to try
and find a way to pay for that
themselves
not too long ago i was diagnosed with
ovarian cancer
and they really came through so far
we've had over 180 thousand dollars
worth of bills
and got close to 75 discounts chm
shared the rest of the expenses to see
if chm is right for you and your budget
check out chministries.org
backslash budget
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five merry christmas
you know this christmas is extra cool
because it's christmas number one but
number two it means that 2020 is almost
over
oh man we're so close
like the it's like the bull with the
cape oh hey
let's just run right on through here 20
20. head on through baby
oh let's take a moment to enjoy that
even in 2020 we get to have christmas
i got everybody on our team little uh
christmas ornaments it's a little
dumpster
dumpster fire says 20 20 on it everybody
got a christmas ornament from dave
sick sense of humor and for almost two
decades
dr john deloney has been a professor a
researcher a community crisis responder
a husband and dad
the guy that's been there for people all
through major trauma
he sits to my right today as my co-host
and he took all this research
we created a new quick read it's only 84
pages it's called redefining
anxiety which is only ten dollars and uh
they've been flying out of here the
sales are record numbers it's
apparently there's a lot of anxiety that
needs to be redefined out there
and how to get your life back through
some
practical steps some long-term
strategies and uh
all of this is ten dollars of course all
of our books just about ten dollars
total money makeovers ten dollars
go to daveramsey.com and backslash store
you can get redefining anxiety
what it is what it's not and how to get
your life back
for ten dollars or less and most of our
best-selling books are ten dollars
the total money makeover among them all
of chris hogan's rachel cruz's ken
coleman's christy writes anthony
o'neill's
ten dollars check them all out the ten
dollar sale
ends at the end of the month at the end
of this
year so then we're going up on the
prices so
yeah we really are i'm laughing about it
but it seems kind of weird but yeah
so ten dollars i mean you can get like a
case of books for a hundred bucks that's
a lot and you mix and match you don't
have to get all one kind whatever you
want to do
and uh been been pretty cool stuff to
watch these books work
redefining anxiety among them beth
is on the line beth is in washington d.c
hi beth how can we help
hello i am 32 i started baby step
2 four years ago with a hundred and
twenty six thousand dollars in student
loans
today i am proud to say i am down to 11
000.
way to go yeah um but i've had to
overcome some pretty substantial
setbacks and baby steps too
so after i finished graduate school i
landed a job in my field of health care
and injury prevention
but i quickly found out i would always
have work but i won't always get paid
for it
i went to work every day for 19 months
not knowing if i was gonna get laid off
and i worked numerous side gigs to the
point that i was sleeping less than four
hours a night for many days a week
i started and stopped my baby step two
so many times
due to job insecurity and also having to
move a thousand miles for my current job
in bc
during baby step two i struggled with
anxiety depression
self-harm because i endlessly shame
myself for the financial mess
that i'm in and i feel so behind the
rest of my peers
i turn to dave's podcast for
encouragement which do help
but i have found that my mental health
issues can sometimes get worse because
so many people on the show are paying
off their debt in much less time
which makes me feel like even more of a
failure i've been living on scorched
earth
which has absolutely helped me pay down
debt but i feel like i'm also scorched
because
yeah i use my mental health and the
problem with the proverbial candle at
both ends kiddo
i mean you went beyond gazelle intense
you didn't even feed the gazelle while
he was running
but i i wholeheartedly agree and i'm one
of those people i'm an all or nothing
i can tell and i'm definitely i'm in
therapy and which has been a lifesaver
and i'm a huge advocate of therapy but
i'm just really curious if others that
have had
an obstacle ridden baby step two like
myself if
they feel the same way and i kind of
feel like a lot of times i'm alone
no you're not i was just talking about
what happens
is this gazelle intense thing is so
weird
it's hard to get some people to turn it
on and it's so hard to get some people
to turn it off
you know and so there's very few people
like that are like the perfectly middle
gazelles
some of them are like lazy fat gazelles
or some of them are starving the boy to
death and running him
haggard like you've been doing and
there's all kinds of internal
motivations in both cases or lack of
internal motivation
motivations in both cases i your journey
sounds a lot like mine beth
i went crazy then stopped and then gave
up and then started sprinting again
and then i realized i left my wife
behind and so i thought the wise thing
would be to drag her along and then we
both stopped then we started walking and
um then there became like dave said is
finding that balance
all depression anxiety all those are you
know this is they're just alarms
telling you that you're not whole and
that you are find yourself alone out on
an island
and you know those things right so yeah
i don't want you to feel alone for a
second in this journey because we hear
this stuff
all the time so john let me ask you
something because i uh
i'm gonna talk about beth right in front
of her here okay um
does it help because obviously she's got
great intellect
just listening to her how articulate she
is and
apparently she wrote all that out
because i think she was reading it does
it help to digest it that way because
does it help her get on top of it
to look down on that piece of paper and
see because you just self-analyzed the
whole thing beth while we were listening
to you
you didn't even like need us you'd
already bounce it off the ground and you
knew exactly what to do
we're from your intellect right but you
can
intellect and data can be just as
addictive just as distancing
as any number of other distancing
behaviors right like
drinking or running or too much exercise
or too much food
you can over intellectualize things and
get way away from it okay
it can be a separation mechanism okay um
beth why why did you work for 19 months
not knowing whether you're going to get
paid or not
you are too wise and too smart and too
gifted to put yourself in that situation
what was it about that
that season that that you put yourself
through that
i appreciate that question and i was
working for a hospital system in boston
and
unfortunately they just are not one of
the richest hospitals and
yeah so great mentors yes
you worked in the hospital i i
understand hospitals have seasons
every place has seasons where they
struggle why did you choose to stay in
that
ecosystem i looked
for 19 months for another job with the
support of my peers saying that we're
going to give you as much money as we
can as many hours as we can but
unfortunately this is our limit
and i applied for jobs for over a year
and i made it all the way to the very
end and there are i learned the hard way
in 2017 and 18
so many people are hiring from within
and i got all the way to the last thing
and
and basically they said sorry we took
someone else and um
i think for me i kind of hit this rut of
i kept trying and trying and trying to
leave
but i had a paycheck from week to week
for a period of time and it was
stressful and that's why i picked up
side gigs so in the event i went to work
one day and lost my
19 job without pay you went 19 months
with insecurity about whether the check
was going to clear that week
right correct oh okay so beth i want to
back up to the front of this call
you ever you ever have a friend that you
haven't seen him in a long time and you
see him
and you realize they've they've lost 50
or 60 pounds
and it's so incredible to see them and
they're excited and you're excited
but you get that burst of hooray and
they've been living it so long
you know it's they see the the
incremental changes in the mirror as
they go
when you first called and you said
you've been cranking on this deal for
four years
you've paid off a hundred and what is
that fifteen
thousand dollars through a graduate
degree
through insecure paychecks and what did
dave and i do we cheered
as though we haven't seen you in years
and we are so ex
impressed with how far you've come
you've got to step back and use that
intellect get 30
000 feet above this situation and go
wow look at me really really proud of
yourself you need to look in the mirror
and go wow girl look at you
you have stumbled and tripped and
grinded
and that's not even a word you've ground
your way you have dragged and pulled and
sprinted
and you're almost there and i hope you
will take a moment and celebrate you
because you're kicking butt man yeah you
really i mean
the first three minutes were touched
down in the super bowl
and the next several pages
read where all the things that are wrong
it is normal to overdo it
and so give yourself permission to let
off the gas a little bit you are
overdoing it
but you have done an incredible thing to
this point
you didn't do it wrong you just were a
little extreme
so back off a little bit get some sleep
eat
love the girl in the mirror she's a hero
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
one of the things that makes the dave
ramsey show unique from other shows
is that we genuinely care about our
listeners
that's why we are very intentional about
choosing
our advertisers blinds.com
offers high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and then their customer service is truly
unbeatable
they make it simple to shop for blinds
shades and interior shutters from home
with easy online ordering and
free shipping right to your door and
blinds.com will help you every step of
the way
just like they've helped thousands of my
listeners
with free design help by phone and
online
plus they guarantee the perfect fit
go today and take advantage of this
week's
special offer
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host
today this is the dave ramsey show nikki
is in denver hi nikki welcome to the
show how can we help
hi dave hi dr john thank you so much for
taking my call
um i'm a little nervous so bear with me
no trouble
um i am currently in baby step
two set to be done by the middle of 2021
and i'm starting to look ahead at baby
step
3b once i have my emergency fund all set
and i'm wondering what it
looks like in the denver market
considering it's so expensive
i make fifty two thousand dollars a year
and i'm not expecting it to go up a time
in the next
couple of years
how do you look at buying real estate
in a market that's so expensive making
as little as i am you don't
okay you don't you also don't need to be
on the bentley lot
yeah you don't have the money to look at
a maserati
right so what are we going to do well
you have two options okay
when you make 52 000 a year you cannot
live in
orange county and buy a decent home
right you cannot live in manhattan and
buy a decent home
and right now it's very tough to live in
denver proper and buy a decent home
making 52 000.
the average household income in america
today is 59
000 and the average home price
median home price is 219 000.
denver is probably i'm going to guess
and say it's around 300
000. san diego san diego's 400
now i'm saying the median home price
there's plenty a half million dollars to
get there but the median home price
in in san diego is about 440 right now
and denver's not as high as san diego
so um but it is high and so
you're going to struggle mathematically
to buy a home
in a market that is 30 above the rest of
the nation in
house price and your household income is
less than average
of the nation household income to even
break even with that scenario you'd have
to be in an area where the houses were
cheaper
than the national average because you
make a little less than
the national average does that make
sense that makes sense
doesn't mean you can't buy a house but
i'm just saying to mathematically break
even on this discussion
so what do you do well there's one of
two things you're going to do
you're going to relocate or you're going
to change careers
i guess three things the third thing is
you're gonna have a longer commute
you're gonna get outside the city of
ways
right and there's a thing called ring
theory
in urban development that if you drop a
pebble in the middle of a downtown area
a simple city not one that's got six
different downtown areas but
a basic downtown area like nashville or
austin or denver has a singular
central business district it doesn't
have three different ones
it's not dallas fort worth okay it's got
it's got one
downtown area and so you drop a pub
pebble in the middle of that and those
rings go out like a
like when you drop it into a pond the
further out those rings you go
the less expensive the real estate is
except for
views and water and views and water will
screw that theory up
good views far out good water views
far out in the case of denver far enough
out you're in the edge of ski
country it's going to go up fast okay
but
if you go out the other way uh you're
going to find
eventually i don't know how many whether
it's an hour commute or what where
you're going to be to where the
house prices drop a little bit but the
reality is your income's going to go up
to match the market that you're in or
we're going to say out loud you cannot
afford to live in silicon valley
making 52 000 a year you can't make it
it's not enough well that's not fair i'm
sorry it's not about fairness it's about
math
that's one of my favorite questions i've
ever heard asked on this show
because i think that there's this
perception and this
i'm so glad that nikki called and had
the courage to ask
there's a perception that oh there must
be like a secret i don't know about
or it might be okay like math doesn't
count here because i'm in california
right so yeah i'm gonna go and buy a
house in denver because this is what
they cost here
yeah so i get that it's all going to
work out yeah no it's not it's not you
go bankrupt
that's exactly right how quickly we
forgot in 2009 in california
when millions lost their house
right well and now millions are leaving
right so what are we gonna do now is
gonna be a bunch of houses on the market
so
just weird world we live in you guys but
math works everywhere it's
it's the international language you not
get a pass on math because of your
geographic location what i have found
though
is remarkably consistent especially in
the 40 50 60
000 range that salary depending on the
field
will be consistent throughout multiple
markets
even though the house won't right so a a
university professor makes about ish
depending on where they live you can get
a lot of bang for your buck in kansas
city versus denver right yeah
or in other states cities here in in
tennessee et cetera
yeah yeah absolutely i mean in middle
america
i mean it's just you're not going to
live in the uber expensive
fringe cities so you're not going to
live in south beach in miami
right you know where uh it's almost as
expensive as manhattan
in terms of per square foot for a little
condo i mean it's just
rowdy and so but that's a little strip
in miami i mean it doesn't take long to
get out of that
and driving straight up the coast and
you start driving inland and up the
coast
you can drop your prices pretty quick
and
you know uh there's a lot of options but
it's
it's all about the commute or all about
your career choice or whatever
but somehow there's something about it
too and she didn't have this in her
voice but i've heard it
over the years it just says well this is
what i make and i should be able to
there's an
entitlement thing i should be able to
buy a house for that well no you can't
you can't
you can't you can't buy a bentley either
you can't buy a maserati
i remember when i was young i was
frustrated that that many people made
that much more money than me
and that was a humility i would drive
through those neighborhoods and go
where's all this money
how does it happen where's all these
people get all this money right
who can afford how come they can just
stack six million dollar houses beside
each other
where do all these people come from
that's that's the neighborhood i grew up
in that's how i was taught to talk
that's exactly that's and then i got to
know a bunch of them and they don't
really have that much money they're just
deeply in debt that's right
but but they make enough to afford the
payments on a 6 million
or a 5 million or a million dollar i
remember the first time you just
you know this neighborhood we live in
here a million is cheap
in williamson county where we live and
um
high media it's the highest household in
our highest household income and highest
median home price in the state of
tennessee and one of the highest in the
nation
because it's just ridiculously affluent
and but it's the same thing you drive
through and go they're putting up these
1.2 million dollar houses like they're
freaking row houses right
they're everywhere and in tennessee
that's a nice
big house i mean that's this is not 1.2
million in l.a and so
that's a beautiful property what you
could get for that
i mean lights out amazing and so um
but i'm you drive through there going
where's all this money coming from
where's
what do these people do you know there's
a couple things we know they don't do
you know and so
uh because you can't afford to live
there doing that
but it's like our friends sitting out
here we're talking a while ago from
queens i mean it's
just a different world real estate
prices different world
then um what you can buy in queens
versus what you could buy within a mile
of here
right for the same dollars it's just um
absolutely amazing but the math
still applies yeah right the more you
still can't pay the freaking payment
there you go you still have to have
money left over to feed your children
there's no magic
when you get done it's like well real
estate just cost this yeah well you
can't afford to live there that's what
we're saying
you just can't make it nikki didn't have
that in her voice she's asking an
honest uh fair good
question and it's a it's a really good
discussion so
how long would you tell a young person
let's let's pretend nicky was 25
26 to rent to live in a location they
want to live in
versus move to a location where they can
begin to put equity in a house henry
cloud talks about necessary endings that
you end a relationship
when there's no hope for the future
meaning he's he's not going to quit
drinking
this boss is not going to quit being
toxic so i got to end this relationship
and i'm going to
end my relationship with that city or
with my with my job when i
can't prosper here ah i like that word
okay
meaning i don't make enough to make it
here gotcha
and so i'm gonna be a renter forever on
lower socioeconomic rungs
that's not prospering and so i've got to
re-situate
something one of these variables has got
to move love it and you could play it
for a few years but you got to play it
with the idea
that there's a place to go with this
that gets me out of this not necessarily
out of the locale
but out of the mess i like that this is
the dave ramsey show
[Music]
in one heart
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today
brittany is with us in ann arbor hi
brittany welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi there dave hi dr john how are you
great how can we help
so i grew up in a really really poor
family
and i married into a family who's super
good with money
since my husband and i got married we
paid off 58 000 in our debt but we still
have 36 000 to go
good um my parents keep
asking us for money though because we
had been open and honest at the
beginning that we were doing the dave
ramsey
plan because we were hoping that they
would follow along
too but they think now that because
we've paid off so much that we have a
lot more money in our months to work
with
and never asking for money and making me
feel bad about not helping them
i don't intend to help them and i told
them no and they've laid down that
boundary but they keep asking and in
private i feel really bad
how do i deal with the feelings of shame
from my parents
why do you feel bad because i feel like
i'm letting them down
so beyond the feel one of the things i
tell people all the time is to
demand evidence from your feelings is
that a true statement are you letting
down your parents
i don't know no you know they're
grown-ups who are choosing
yeah like they should know how to deal
with this
but they weren't taught how to deal with
their money either and they don't want
to take
from me saying that we should do dave
ramsey together because
they're they're my parents and so
they're thinking like what the heck does
she know
and so you're good enough to give them
money but not good enough to give them
advice well that's an interesting
arrogance
that's right so i will help you with
your with your
with your algebraic equation demanding
evidence does a plus b
equal c in this one no your parents are
making a grown-up decision to do
grown-up things with their money
and they're making a childish immature
decision to hit their child up for money
because they can't be disciplined
themselves
you were released from that you're doing
a hard
wise adult thing and you're setting up
boundaries for yourself and your family
you've done a hard thing which is to
communicate those to your parents
and those are the hardest and then
they're going to keep banging their head
up against those boundaries to see if
they hold
and let me tell you just i'll just say
out loud okay this is papa dave
all right the fact that they even ask
you for money
is wrong
that's wrong thank you this is wrong
they don't have rights to your money
the fact that they put you in that
corner and make you feel that way is
just wrong
it's just wrong and um it's child abuse
it's adult child abuse and um
uh you know there's something in their
upbringing that makes them think that
it's okay
well we're all family that's why we say
when we're hillbillies right
we're all family and that that means
you're supposed to put up with toxic
bullcrap
that's what that phrase means we're all
family which right
that it means you're supposed to
tolerate stupidity
and just embrace it because it's part or
we're family
nope nope nope you're crazy
because you're building a new family
right a new legacy
you're you're ending that nonsense with
you and
here we talk about boundaries a lot and
we also talk about it the the
the the cycle stop with you
and when they talk about it in in
therapeutic sessions they talk about a
raging forest fire that someone finally
stops and turns and faces down
what they don't tell about that metaphor
is that when you stop and face down a
forest fire you get burned it hurts
and that's where you are right now it
sucks it's hard yeah
and your kids are not gonna have to deal
with this nonsense because you took one
for the legacy you took one for the
family tree you're changing the family
tree
and it hurts but you're doing right so
the only way you can
uh have these discussions anymore is
just say
a we're not gonna have any more
discussions about this mom and dad
the answers are perpetual no
no or okay or
if you want to help after you're out of
your baby step two you can't help at all
while you're in baby step two you're not
allowed i'm not gonna let you
okay dave said you suck
no okay so no don't tell them that but
just tell them dave said no
and so um but the uh
once you have some money but right now
you're broken in debt
okay so you don't have any money so we
don't need to talk about you being
outrageously generous to somebody i mean
you'd be tithing if you're a christian
or whatever but that that's you know but
giving money away to in
to enable relatives is not it's not even
on your list right now you're trying to
get out of debt
get your emergency fund but once you're
in baby step four if you want to reach
over
and pay a 500 bill or something that
has to come if it's coming from my house
here's what it would sound like
to a friend or a family member i'm going
to give you a gift
of 500 one time
on the condition that you complete
financial peace university and if you're
unwilling to go to the class
and complete that then i'm unwilling to
make you the gift because i am not
going to give a cocaine addict money for
their cocaine
and you when it comes to money are a
cocaine addict you are misbehaving
and you have for decades
and i love you enough to tell you that
and when you quit misbehaving i will
fund your recovery
i will not fund your misbehavior because
that's called enabling
enablers are sweet people but they do
not help
they actually harm when you give a drunk
a drink
you are actually causing them to be a
drunk
you're not blessing them
that's why we were saying no yes you're
really not helping yourself every day
yeah you're really not helping and it's
just so hard now i will tell you this
too what john says
true the forest fire is going to burn
this is going to hurt and it's not
going to quit hurting i'm not going to
tell you that here's why
your spiritual dna is designed to want
to please
your heavenly father that same
connective tissue
is the connective tissue you have to
your mom and dad
and so your desire to please them will
not go away
as long as you breathe
the problem is that while you try desire
to please god he is perfect in his love
towards you
they are imperfect in their love towards
you and so you have to set up boundaries
but you're not going to get away from
the desire to please your parents as
long as you breathe
even after they're dead some people
spend half their uh
60s and 70s trying to please dead
parents
trying to live up to my daddy's
expectations and he's been gone for 20
years and that kind of a thing so your
desire to please your parents is built
into your spiritual dna
you're not going to get away from that
and that's why it hurts that's why it
hurts
but you got to give your and so what
dave is saying you got to give yourself
some space
when those feelings come they're real
you acknowledge them
and then you demand evidence and then
you realize no i'm doing the right thing
yeah
and then you can go about your day yeah
my desire to please my dad is a natural
thing my desire to please my mom is a
natural thing
their request is unnatural right and
toxic
and wrong and morally wrong and so i
that's where you have to separate it and
there's there's some people dave that
prey
on that well they do they're called
travel agent for guilt trips right right
they
prey on that on that desire to please
yep right
yep yeah and they know how to manipulate
it oh yeah how to play it and so
and again sometimes it's a cultural
thing it's like i i
i can hear it not my family didn't do
this but i've heard it in
the neighborhood the hillbilly elegy
that i grew up in kind of a thing and
it's just like
well you know it's family and you got to
take care of family
regardless of how stupid and out of
control and toxic they are i have to
take care of them
well maybe not maybe he needs to stay in
jail a while he drinks
every weekend and beats his wife it's a
good idea for him to stay there i don't
care if he's family you know what i mean
maybe the
the best way to help out right yeah
that's what he needs to be incarcerated
this guy needs to be off the street he
happens to be my brother but you know
it's like
that's not my case but i mean i've
watched this kind of stuff my whole life
and it's like well they're family that
doesn't matter
it means you overlook complete disasters
no we don't overlook it we love them in
spite of that
but that doesn't mean we're going to
embrace the stupidity right
and endorse it and make it a part of our
the rhythm of our life and the rhythm of
our children's lives as a result and
you got to break the cycle not even the
rhythm it's it's the
the soul and integrity and strength of
your family and your marriage and your
kids and wherever you're headed right
and the netflix movie i think sucks but
the book was one of the best books i've
ever read hillbilly elegy by j.d vance
that's extraordinary and it's
extraordinary book
and um the uh because the
book itself talks about how he broke the
cycle he gave honor to his upbringing
and yet broke the cycle and both those
things are accomplished beautifully not
in the screenplay
but in the book this is the dave ramsey
[Music]
show
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character
you can have money and a career
you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the dave ramsey
show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host dr john deloney ramsey
personality is my co-host today
author of the best-selling book
redefining anxiety
so we're taking your questions about
family about anxiety
about any issues you might have
including your money
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five ben is in nashville hi
ben welcome to the dave ramsey show
hey uh mr ramsay thank you for taking my
call sure
um i've been through financial peace
university and
um i learned a lot through that and
i started paying off some debt um
basically i've made some bad decisions
here in the last
five months and i don't want to try to
validate it with excuses
so i'll just tell you where i'm at um i
make about 95 000
a year uh it's in an unstable market in
construction management so i'm not
really guaranteed that job two months
from now
but that's what i've made uh in the last
year
and i've got nineteen thousand dollars
in student loans
and a 83 000 mortgage and that's all my
debt
and then this summer i decided to go buy
a 69 000 vehicle and
i'm a single man 36 years old and
in that time i met the woman of my
dreams in the last three months
that as she listens to dave ramsey as
well so it blew my mind and i'm just
like
what have i done i had a mentor that i
told
what i was doing and buying a vehicle
and obviously i said i know this is not
a smart
decision uh it's almost as much as my
mortgage so i said but i can afford the
payments right now
i'm good so that's my situation i know
i've made some mistakes
and i'm i'm i'm coming to you now
because
since i've met her um i kind of
kind of want to get out from uh from the
debt even faster and i don't know if you
would recommend maybe just filling this
vehicle
getting out from under it paying off
what uh what i'm going to lose on
selling it
and uh and move on
um so what'd your mentor say
when you told them you're going to buy a
69 000 truck
i i didn't tell him until after it was
done he just saw it in the parking lot
and uh i could see his eyes kind of
raised you know like oh okay well
you know it was almost that second-hand
embarrassment that i could feel through
him
um that's fair so what happened
that that hit that domino that made you
go by that did something happen in your
life you get tired you get burnt out you
exhausted
what happened well if i look back yeah i
was in a long relationship
about nine years and i just got out of
that in march and um
i bought this vehicle about three months
ago thinking hey i'm out you know i have
very little debt
um my nieces and nephew were two and a
half hours three hours away
and uh now they've moved within 30
minutes
and they're being homeschooled and i'd
like to be near them
so i was like you know let's get a
vehicle that can get the whole family
uh involved including those three kids
and
you know mom and dad too and uh
for sixty nine thousand they all ought
to be able to live in it
yeah i agree uh okay all right well
here's the thing
how old are you 36
you said that earlier i'm sorry um i
have done so many stupid things in my
life
that have cost me so much money and
embarrassment
and shame and when i do something stupid
i call it stupid tax that i have to pay
and part of the stupid taxes money and
part of it is just i look in the mirror
and i go you're a
doofus and i kind of hear that's what
you're doing right now am i missing
something
no it sums it up yeah after meeting her
i realized that
no you knew it all along she just made
you admit it you knew it when you drove
it off the lot you were just holding
your nose hoping the smell wasn't gonna
go away
you knew it there you knew it because
you had been trained by us
you've been through financial peace
university you knew it you knew when you
called me what i was going to say you
hid it from your mentor that's the big
you made it into a secret that's how you
really knew yeah you knew you knew all
along
so here's the thing anytime i do and i'm
not picking on because i've done dumber
things i've done 690 000 stupid things
you're only 69 000 you'll survive this
but uh the trick is not what to do with
this
the trick is to do enough of an autopsy
on your psyche
and on yourself to where you freaking
never do this again
that's a big deal why because it's a
pattern
and if you don't change the pattern
you're screwed
because i i if i engage in a pattern of
stupidity
that then makes me called stupid and you
you know
you gotta you gotta no longer do that so
to be worthy of this girl
is what you're the noble the calling
inside of your heart you wanna be a
wise young gentleman not a
not the doofus that you saw in the
mirror after you bought the truck and
so but if she dumps you in three months
yeah it's still the right thing to not
have bought
the motivation is very noble right and
that can cause you to go i'm going to
break
this pattern when i went broke the
motivation was noble i said
i am never going to be here again i'm
never going to be in a situation where i
can't feed my kids again i'm embarrassed
my stupidity has caused my family to
have the lights cut off the water cut
off
my wife is ready to leave i because of
my stupidity i have to stop
the stupid and i had to do a csi on why
i
did the things i did that set me up for
the fall and i had to never do them
again
so that's what's important the truck is
just the symptom does that make sense
ben
it does so if you dig this out and this
is like the dumbest
last thing you ever do in this category
that's a huge win if you just sell the
truck and you don't dig it out
and you go back next time there's
something going on and you go buy a boat
and you go wow i just wanted to get a
boat and i just thought well i can
afford the payments you know the same
thing you did last time
then you're gonna just replicate this
and you're gonna be what's known as
normal in america
and you just don't be normal man normal
sucks
that's why you called us so i'm not
spanking you i'm going with you on this
i'm saying the answer to your question
is not about the truck the answer this
question's down inside of you
you fixed that and then you already know
you got to sell the truck the truck was
just off the chain it's got to go
but that's a side issue of course the
truck's got to go
it's dad gum almost as much as you make
in a year of course the truck has to go
it was a stupid idea to start with of
course the truck has to go
you don't rationalize i'm gonna visit
people three hours away and spend eighty
thousand dollars to do that
you go rent a car you go rent a house
over there cheaper than that
it's gonna say you can rent a house for
five to ten years and yeah cheaper than
uber over there
exactly you can you know charter a jet
cheaper than this
and go see them twice a year you know i
mean it's just so it's yeah there's a
lot of stuff you could do
so you can't use it you got to go okay
that didn't work that didn't work
that didn't work i knew dave wasn't
gonna be happy with this i knew my
mentor wasn't gonna be happy with this
is it because it affected dave or my
mentor no it's because they love me
and they want good things for me and
this wasn't good for me
and i got to not do stuff that's not
good for me anymore and know why i'm
doing it and break that cycle
and sell the truck let this be the last
one
brother i i do a lot of stupid stuff i
just try to not do the same stupid stuff
over again
and then if you do that long enough
eventually they call you wise this is
the dave ramsey show
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country or have a
better life
the army national guard can help get you
there plus they
offer unbelievable financial benefits
secure your future today
visit nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
[Music]
you know whenever people do their
debt-free screams i always ask them what
the key was
to getting out of debt and they almost
always say budget and they almost always
say communication and being on the same
page
and that's because a budget puts you in
control of every dollar that you bring
in every month
you tell it where to go instead of
wondering where it went when you start a
ramsey plus membership you follow a
step-by-step
plan that we give you where you budget
you learn how to manage money the right
way and you get fired up as you make
progress towards your debt-free
wealth-building outrageously generous
giving
journey and that's why we include every
dollar
the best budgeting tool in the world in
your ramsey plus membership
you get customer reports on your
spending habits and you'll connect
straight to your bank
so your transactions show up right in
your budget
the right way right away and
you can try it all for free with a trial
to ramsey plus
a free trial don't wait another day
start your free trial of ramsey plus
text the word
begin to 33 789
that's 33 789
text begin to 33789
so zach bennett here at ramsey solutions
is on our radio
and video team one of our producers
around here
has been with us for a decade plus he
does all the video on
the john doloni show too he's a savant
he's awesome
yeah so he sends me the statistics here
these stats he says i'm a nerd like you
dave
thanks zach 247 debt free screams on the
air this year this is a slow year
because of covid
uh the lobby was shut down here and uh
we spent a month and a half not doing
debt-free scrims just taking calls from
people that were struggling
with getting laid off and all the
craziness with the lockdown back in the
spring so
jeffrey's screams were suspended for a
little while so it's an unusually low
year usually kelly they're about
45 to 50 million a year roughly is that
about right
that's about right and debt free screams
with total for the year
of the people doing the screaming this
year it's going to be a little less
going to be about 28 million
184 in the lobby 63 on the phone
heavy lobby screams though hmm go figure
and uh uh average debt paid off per
caller this is interesting
this one this is numbers i haven't seen
before uh take the average of
you know per debt free screamer was 114
000
average time that they took to pay off
their debt
30.14 months we had 18
ramsey team members who did debt-free
screams
uh totaling a million four that's cool
41 states and two canadian provinces
were represented in the debt-free
screamers california 18
florida 17 texas 16 illinois 14 indiana
13 ohio 12 pennsylvania 11
and tennessee 10 that's the top 10 of
the 167 or the 6 was 167 that would say
it
was
where'd it go a 247 yeah okay
and uh and he goes month by month
through the whole thing and of course we
see the drop off
uh there in april when there was almost
no debt-free screams and that dropped us
behind our images but that's interesting
114 over 30 months
all over the united states and uh 114
000 average so that kind of gives you
guys that are working on your debt
snowball
some encouragement to get through it and
we have this little stage here that free
stage it's waiting on you
two and a half years so over 30 years
dave what is the secret ben somebody
gets fired up they take off sprinting
them and their husband take off
sprinting through the woods
like a good gazelle three months in
what's the shot in the arm that's gonna
go two and a half two and a half years
is a long time and i'm thinking through
it like
fixing your marriage fixing your your
relationship with your parents i'm
thinking it like weight loss
i know the stats there two and a half
years is a season that's a long
long time uh the motivation shifts
on the ones that make it okay when
people start out
they start all of us do this me include
you included we start out
like a cold shower just screaming
braveheart
right a cold shower screaming braveheart
no i'm talking about i get that on a
t-shirt you know what i'm talking about
you just gotta
run it's gonna grind i'm just gonna i'm
gonna i'm gonna i'm just gonna
run into this concrete block wall until
it falls over that's right
right and and that gets you started that
sets a new groove in your brain
it causes you to sell the car have a
garage sale sell so much stuff the kids
are next stay out of restaurants
you know take the extra job it causes
you to do the stuff right to get moving
and that will last
90 days some people can do it for nine
months
mine is about 90 days about three months
very few people can do that for a year
they're very very unusual it's a
psychological disorder if you can do it
again
i mean i mean it's just it's ah just the
just the sheer
raw emotion the guttural scream right
but what happens is as they start to win
they start to believe and it's not just
this
sheer desperation sheer anger sheer
disgust raw emotion that's driving them
now it starts to be hope hope that i'm
really going to get out
and when you start to believe then you
start to look past the debt
and go i'm going to change my family
tree uh i'm doing this for these babies
i'm looking at
and that's a different kind of emotion
that's not a screaming
braveheart emotion that comes deep from
within that's the kind of emotion you
die for
that's right that's the kind of honor
nobility
dignity change my family tree higher
calling
i want to be generous like i've never
been before and the emotion starts to
come from
caring for others rather than self
and when it shifts off of you that 90
day
nine month mark six month mark whatever
it is that's the ones that complete
if you just keep it on you i want to be
rich to be rich for me because i'm
richie rich and i want to have the bling
and i want to have the car
it's a hollow hollow life shallow and
there's not a lot of energy in it that's
right
and it runs out it runs out people don't
make it selfish
motivation in other words they'll get
you started but it won't keep you going
and there's a switch that flips a a it's
not a switch it's
go over the hill whatever it is like
it's a smooth or it's rough or whatever
but you go over
and all of a sudden there's a green
valley and it's all about others
it's a godly man leaves an inheritance
to his children's
children i i remember having the thought
i'm going to make so much money if my
kids are screw up so they can't go
through it all
huh and that means the kids the
grandkids are going to have something
yep you know now i didn't want to do
that i didn't i really didn't want to be
screw-ups and i wanted to leave money if
they were screw-ups that's dysfunctional
but i remember having the mathematical
thought of
i mean you really i mean you think about
standard oil you know jp morgan those
guys and
they made so much money that four
generations later they still can't go
through it they can't burn through it
they still can't go through it
and it's ruined some of them some of
them didn't make it you know and and
i remember i remember when they became
trust fund babies but with a workout
plan
when i went from yeah i want to look
great to
from vanity i want to be able to roll
around on the floor with my grandkids
and then suddenly you get up every
morning yeah right
from vanity to uh and i want the pants
to legacy yep
to i am tired of being tired
when i'm playing with my three-year-old
two my
son got quarantined and had to do a
couple of uh
weeks at home on a zoom class
and dave we don't talk about it it's not
something that we beat in it's just
something
you get up every day and we're going to
be stewards of our body we're going to
take care of ourselves
and he said i've got to go sprint dad
and he walked out the door and took off
running down the driveway and i thought
that's how legacy change happens yeah
not by barking and yelling but we're
going to do it we're going to do it
and then this christmas it's been i
think my sister's really going to love
this gift
this is this is when it turned it's not
about what am i going to get what am i
going to get it's
hey can we go can we go to the store one
more time get something for mom right
and it starts to shift
it's a maturity and it's just it's just
a nickel and a dime at
a time it's maturity and it's by degrees
and that's why i say it's not all of a
sudden you're going along in braveheart
cold water mode and then you just switch
to noble grandpa that's not it doesn't
happen in one fell thing
but there is a movement in the spirit to
where and i think it is associated with
hope when you first start you're not
sure this is going to work
i'm just going i got to do something
something's got to change
i got gotta bust into this but then when
you knock off and you go man i paid off
those first six deaths in that death
snowball this the snowball's actually
rolling
and the concrete really the evidence in
front of me indicates that i should have
hope those steps get firmer right yeah
and then you're like
that gum yeah we can run baby we're
doing this man game on
game on baby you know and and all of a
sudden that hope kicks in hope deferred
makes the heart sick
but when desire comes it is the tree of
life
this is the dave ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
cliff and i joined christian healthcare
ministries because we really liked the
concept
of christians sharing each other's
burdens
and we really experienced that firsthand
when cliff
was diagnosed with heart disease
christian healthcare ministries
or chm is not health insurance
but rather a federally approved
exemption to the health care law
it's a time-tested model to help take
care of your health care costs
it's christians helping other christians
by sharing each other's medical bills
adjusting to a new system of paying for
health care
was kind of tricky but that's where chm
stepped in
and they really helped navigate that
water
with the hospital and the payment want
to see if chm is the right fit for your
healthcare needs
check out our website at
chministries.org backslash budget
that's chministries.org backslash
budget it was just such a relief to know
that financial burden was going to be
taken care of
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host open phones at triple eight
eight two five
five two two five derrick's in kansas
city hi derek how are you
oh mr ramsay i'm doing well how are you
doing better than i deserve how can we
help
oh good hey so i got a question my
growing up uh i wasn't super financially
responsible
and yeah and i think that's how we are
as kids
try not to be i've gotten a lot better
um
over the years credit scored out high i
ended up moving from san diego to kansas
city about three years ago
i had some credit card debt that i
turned into being irresponsible again
probably i don't know five years ago um
ended up getting charged off
and i owe about 8 900 well i got a
notification in the mail the other day
about a court hearing on the 30th of
this month
obviously to get their money back which
is fair um
i guess my question is uh what i've done
is i called them and tried to do a
settlement
um for a percentage of the total amount
they agreed to it
i just agreed to a higher rate than i
was comfortable paying at the time
and now i'm left with the decision of do
i pay that amount or i also have a truck
that i only owe
8 200 on if i pay that off
do you have any money i do so i have
about 12 000
in savings okay what can you get the
credit card company to agree to settle
for right now um
five thousand okay that's pretty high
how old is the debt
oh gosh i would say five years uh
for they were they paid about a nickel
on the dollar for it
okay so on a ten thousand dollar debt
they paid 500 bucks for it okay
roughly would you recommend getting an
attorney i got a ton of emails
no i just want you to beat them i just
want you to beat on them a little harder
and get them down to about 3k
three okay i had offered 35 yeah after
doing some research online and
there's like 60 and they said no that
that company will never go that low
and yeah yes they will um i know it so
what you've got to do is just keep
messing with them and just go well
i you know i have four thousand dollars
if you want to settle this today
we can settle it today now here's a
couple of rules
number one you can tell a credit card
collector is lying if their mouth is
moving
it's scum that you're dealing with sure
bottom feeders and so and if you're a
credit card collector out there and you
don't like me saying that you should get
a different job to prove that you're not
scum
so uh because nobody stays in that
business it's not scummy it is a
nasty butt business they lie
i am not kidding you we've dealt with
them for 30 years
major household names like american
express
bank of america citibank will lie
to you it is unbelievable okay
it's hard to believe and you think i'm
being melodramatic i'm not i've done
this for a long time
first time or two it happened to me i
was shocked but it's just the way it is
so get it in writing or it didn't happen
okay and it can be an email that's fine
but an email from that organization and
with the account number on it
and it says this account is settled in
full
if you pay four thousand dollars by
january 15th or whatever okay okay
then you do not rule number one
in writing or it didn't happen rule
number two is they do not get electronic
access
to your checking account under any
circumstances
they will clean you out they'll take 8
900 out of your
account if you give them the account
that's got 8 900 in it
and then try to get that back because
you owe it you're not getting it back
so you need a prepaid debit card that is
transacted one time
and then closed a wire is fine
uh but i i wouldn't give them electronic
access to a bank account under
any circumstances a traditional bank
account because they'll take your money
out and you won't be able to pay your
rent
okay in writing no electronic access to
your checking account
got it yes sir and you ought to be able
to get them down to four anyway you
already got them to five
i'm really surprised they wouldn't take
3 500 i really am
yeah so i guess it's is that normal for
it's not at this agency anymore i don't
know if i'm allowed to say the company
they bounce it around all over the place
they've probably sold the debt for a
nickel on the dollar and the people
collecting it are sitting in a boiler
room
with a you know there's a whole room
full of cubicles with people with
headsets on
dialing people like you okay yeah that's
right it's an attorney i ended up
calling that no they're not they work
for an attorney
and they've got 72 000 of them in this
one room
it's a boiler room they have one
attorney in there and you're just
you're just a widget this is not matlock
so do you think the 3000 or 3500 i
should be good with that or should it be
three to four if you can settle this for
three or four and you've got the money
and you can get it out of your life
finally
get it out of your life but again in
writing no electronic access your
checking account
okay you're dealing with a debt buyer
they bought
a million dollars worth of debt for a
nickel on the dollar and they're out
there collecting it and they finally
found somebody that their phone number
actually worked
sure or you called them so now they got
your phone number do not give them any
information by the way on you
like where you work or anything else
about you
yeah that's too late so they had asked
that um i'd let them know
um didn't know i should have called you
sooner yeah well they're going to use
that against you too because they're
going to garnish your dad gum wages if
they take this judgment now
or they'll call you where you work yeah
they're going to bug the crap out of you
show your admin or your boss so settle
this three four five thousand somewhere
in there get it settled
uh you know uh and you know i would just
tell the guy listen i have money in my
hand
if you want credit for this account
before christmas we can do the deal
right now
you want to play let's dance baby and
just mess with him
because he's not used to actually
talking to people he's used to leaving
voicemails all day long and he actually
talking to a person
he doesn't he's about to wet himself he
doesn't know how to handle this and
you're dealing with a guy who's not been
on the job even 90 days
their turnover rate inside these
collection companies like this is about
40 days
most people make it a a month and 10
days and then they're gone to something
else because it's a job it's the worst
job in the world it sucks
how would you like to call people all
day long and mess with them
oh god i mean you got to have
psychological disorder to do that as a
career
and so um anyway that's who you're
dealing with is some kid
in a cubicle 500 miles away with a
headset on
think of every movie you've ever seen
you've got it in your head right
that's the deal and just you know just
mess with them
and that it's not a lawyer there is a
lawyer somewhere in the background
but there's there's you're not talking
to a lawyer you're not even talking to a
paralegal
you're not even talking anybody who
could pass the first week of a paralegal
test
so not even close so just mess with them
and push on through and you'll get there
emery is with us in rome new york hi
emory how are you
hi sir thank you for taking my call sure
how can we help okay so uh
uh we're on baby step seven yes uh
yeah we're doing uh pretty pretty good
actually we were going to go to your
cruise and uh then he got cancelled so
uh that's what
i heard about that it was going to be my
first cruise emery and
such it is oh my god yeah we were going
to do our
our battery screen and screen and
everything but
hey so my question is uh
my husband and i are 10 years apart uh
he
is he already retired from the military
uh but we both work for the uh
still for the military as civilians and
uh
we're having a little bit of a
disagreement uh
on when should we retire i still have 10
years
to work for the federal government he's
already
eligible for retirement and we don't
know how to
negotiate a state on how how to retire
does somebody want to keep working or
does somebody want someone to stop
working
[Laughter]
i want to keep working he wants to stop
he said well why can't he not stop and
you keep working what would be wrong
with that
i don't know i i i i didn't feel like
that was correct you know that he said i
get to keep working and he doesn't you
know
well how old are you 47 how old is he
57 okay so if
if you have enough money and you're in
baby step seven and he doesn't want to
work and you want to
that why is that not okay yeah he can
find all i get
he can find a hobby i mean if you want
to i suggest at 57 that you probably got
a few good years left doing something
maybe you don't keep working there but
you probably ought to do something right
it's not good for you to just go fishing
for 42 years
[Laughter]
you ought to do something with your life
but that's just my opinion so
i you know if you can afford it i don't
care if you work or not it's up to you
but i think there's great dignity in
work
amen
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture of the day first peter 4 8
above all keep loving one another
earnestly since
love covers a multitude of sins
merry christmas that wasn't part of the
scripture that was me
hamilton wright mabel's maybe said
blessed
is the season which engages the whole
world in a conspiracy of love
oh that's good blast is with us in
indianapolis hi bless how are you i'm
great yourselves
better than i deserve what's up well um
so here's the deal um i'm currently
engaged
uh to my fiance we've been together for
five years
but she has three wonderful children one
of which
has a lot of special needs the biggest
issue with us getting married is that
he's on medicaid
and if we get married he loses that so
he loses it due to your household income
being too high
that's correct yeah what do you make so
i make seven a year
what does she make uh she's gonna stay
at home
okay so that's why she has no income
right now
exactly that's correct well well she
well sorry she does she knows she's got
child support
and she does get ssi for him so her
monthly is about uh
yeah but i mean as far as the
calculation for his ssi
she's allowed if i remember it's about
three thousand dollars a month
that she can make without canceling out
his ssi
and so by your household income going to
70 it cancels it out
he'll lose the ssi and the medicaid see
ssi and medicare set up for
not special needs they're set up for
welfare
right right for people that are too
broke to eat
but but the problem is is because of his
needs he had he was born with a heart
defect
so his bills get really really really
high
um and i wouldn't doubt that his last
surgery probably broke the millions
do you have do you have health insurance
through your work
i do yes can you not add your family to
it
i could but i'm not sure how that would
affect a pre-existing condition
it's obamacare dude you can add them
okay pre-existing or not you need to you
need to talk to your health insurance
people and your hr benefits and make
sure
but i think you can add them your whole
family to your health insurance plan you
make seventy thousand dollars a year
and this family of uh with three kids
and this lady or your family
and they're gonna be taken care of by
your health insurance plan and by your
income
and so they're getting off of welfare
right right right okay that's what it
means i mean i'm not being cold
that's just what it means medicaid is
for people who don't have an income
it's welfare right right and there's not
it's not evil it's not horrible
it's where she was but we're not gonna
not get married and live in the same
house so we can keep her on welfare
right right that's that's that's morally
wrong
so then so then by us getting married i
can put her
them on my insurance and his medical
condition should be covered in full
or should be it should be but double
check that you don't have to take a
radio guys
that's like you said it's a million
dollar question you don't take my advice
on you check it out for yourself
but it should be the pre-existing
conditions can be added
under obamacare now now say that it's
not covered in full and we still
wouldn't be able to cover the difference
uh like if there's like a copay or you
you cover the copay you can handle a
copay
yeah what about like the 70 80 split or
stuff like that
that's the copay okay okay let me tell
you okay
insurance has three numbers health
insurance and learn about these three
numbers when you talk to your hr group
okay
okay number number one you're familiar
with is the deductible
right and you pay a hundred percent
until you meet the deductible you know
that
right right right number number two
is the copay and it's typically
80 20. they pay 80 you pay 20
once you've hit your deductible the
third number is the important one
in this discussion that'll give you a
lot of peace and that's called stop
loss stop loss okay and that's your
max out of pocket pocket what is your
maximum out of pocket
and typically it's going to be uh
who do you work for what kind of company
just don't tell me who but what kind of
company do you work for
i'm a truck driver okay for over the
road or
in town regional regional local okay is
the company a trucking
outfit
or do you drive for somebody that's like
a walmart or something like that
uh yes exactly exactly okay so they've
probably got good insurance
which means your stop loss your max out
of pocket
is probably in the neighborhood of
10 grand maybe 20 grand
okay and so that if this kid goes in and
has a million dollar surgery your 80 20
your deductible everything added up
when it hits that stop loss it stops and
they pay 100
after that and so if it's a million
dollars and you have a stop loss of 10
thousand dollars
you pay 10 000 they pay 990 000
and that that's what that's the three
numbers you need to understand and then
the last thing you need to understand
is i'm getting married to a lady who has
a child with some special needs
what uh you know what pre-existing
conditions
are how is that work with our policy
here at work
and let hr tell you that and let them
send you the brochures showing you
in writing that this kid is going to be
covered after three months
or this kid is going to be covered after
a year or this kid is going to be
covered from day one
somewhere in there is probably what
you're going to find
i suspect you probably can solve this
problem
and that actually is my concern dave
is i i just hear him doing the math in
his head
on this relationship and he's marrying
somebody with
special needs child he's in love with
somebody saying i'm pledging myself to
her
and the kid for better for worse and
those kids
and if at the end of the day before he
pulls the trigger and gets married
if he says well if that just gets too
expensive then fill in the blank
then he needs to get out and back out
and walk away
well i that that's a possible but i
didn't hear that what i heard was
i want to make sure i'm do i can do my
job
okay and i don't want to set myself up
where i can't take care of this kid i
said i'm going to take care of him and
then
if it's a million dollars i can't do it
that's exactly right okay and i will
make sure i can do it
okay i i i'm giving it that's a much
more noble approach than
than that's right that's okay it could
be either way you don't if it's if it is
dollars and cents then walk
and uh this is the problem though with
the
medicaid ssi the whole welfare system
is it encourages people to not be
married or it disincentivizes people
from
right yeah incur well i mean same thing
the incentive is not to get married
because it screws up everything
and um or it's seen as a forever instead
of a stop gap right
yeah well and you know if you don't have
another way to cover a child that has a
potential million dollar operation
it is forever until you find a way to
cover it so you got it you got to take
care of the babies
and but i'm pretty sure that he can get
this child insured
i might be wrong but i don't think i am
and uh especially if he's working for
a big regional or a big national company
that he happens to be driving truck for
and um they probably have a sweet plan
that would be my guess and even if it's
a little bit expensive do it anyway
right
do it anyway even if it costs you you
know 300
more a month then that hurts a little
bit uh do it right that's good
that's good let's because the family
that is married
and committed economically will
out prosper the family that is shocked
checked up
statistically every time right
economists call it the marriage
benefit it actually causes economic lift
to be married because on average married
people make more than shacked up people
household income on average nationally
and it could be
socio-economic it could be the you know
what's the cause what's the effect
you can argue that if you want to but we
do know statistically
married people make more than shacked up
people make
on average a lot more throughout their
life it's
the marriage benefit that's talked about
and so that's what i want for your
family long term
but in order to do that we have to solve
the short-term
potential issue and make sure that this
child is cared for which is a noble
thing
absolutely it is very very good stuff so
um
there is i have never in 30 years of
being on this error shame someone for
being in medicaid
uh and that includes a nursing home for
medicaid but i will tell you
that when you have the opportunity to
not be in it it is your calling to not
be in it
so when you have the opportunity to buy
long-term care insurance so you don't
have
welfare nursing home which is the only
way the government pays for it is
medicaid
then you should do that you should do
that you should take care of yourself so
somebody else doesn't have to take care
of it right that's pretty basic personal
responsibility stuff and i've said that
all along
so where those options are open that
puts us hour today ramsey showing the
books we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
[Music]
jesus
[Music]
you